master and apprentice have characterized
German trades since the 12th century
so plaster is a busty unhorsed and his
apprentice Johannes Schroeder barons are
part of a long tradition today they're
visiting the construction site at a
Berlin opera house enormous pieces of
plaster and stucco from the auditorium
weigh up to 300 kilograms in a few weeks
they have to be back up on the ceiling
an apprentice must be satisfied with
doing simple tasks in the building next
door many historical rooms of being
renovated scraping off old paint is
tedious so the right attitude is
important please so I've always liked
plaster it's a good substance for
bringing a space to life no matter what
its condition when it looks nice again I
get a sense of freedom stand in the
space and think wow oh you can look at
the ceiling stay thin if there's a
really nice painting on it that's even
better then on a chic Amala right office
all of it
Schroder Berlin's has a soft spot for
beautiful old things before he became an
apprentice he was studying history and
archaeology and was working at his
University now he's 30 and he started a
completely new chapter in his life
Sebastiaan haast has been taking on
apprentices for 20 years he's seen the
good and less gifted come and go as more
Pelham the most important lesson is to
learn to listen listen stand back not
thing I can do it all now they don't get
bullied or harassed but I think that
it's important they definitely approach
things with a certain humility training
is an opportunity to learn regardless of
age that takes modesty also when it
comes to pay the average monthly pay for
an apprentice is less than 800 euros
before taxes
Sebastian lost apprentices except that
trota Bevins experiences what vocational
education is in Germany every Friday
that's when the somewhat older
apprentice climbs into his somewhat
older car and drives across Berlin he
heads for the colobus Dorf occasional
school in the northwest of the city it's
the other part of the dual training
system learning theory in the classroom
about 2,000 trainees attend classes here
they're Masons and surveyors cabinet
makers and mechanics here they learn the
theoretical basics of their jobs
Birgit Hiva is a construction engineer
and has been teaching here for 25 years
that's where Mohammed met we're working
on the superstructure in general what's
special about the companies we then move
on to handling materials for example
because if I know why certain things are
the way they are then I have more
confidence when I'm working pretty
praxis the combination of theory and
practice learning and applying makes
Germany's vocational training system a
dual one it's also what sets it apart
companies and government vocational
schools work in cooperation a
partnership found in few other countries
professor Alfred Lidl of Munich's
Technical University researchers
vocational education at the moment
Germany has 1.4 million apprentices one
reason for its low youth unemployment
rate single argue it is able to do their
jobs in a theoretically considered and
practically competent way since they're
also flexible as a result and can change
firms within the German system once
they've qualified they're in demand as a
rule even outside of the company where
they trained people from abroad have
noticed that giving young people a
future with a model that includes theory
and practice seems to work more and more
countries are expressing an interest in
the German system
but adopting it is easier said than done
the thought Germany's Jule vocational
training system is supported by a high
level of acceptance that's rooted within
the society companies are willing and
eager to take part in training people
and it takes time for that to develop
The Apprentice plasterer has found his
place in Germany's dual training system
he may not be the youngest apprentice
but he's certainly a happy one
Bonneville don't idle it was a good
decision it's fun and I'm looking
forward to doing something new and that
motivates me that makes getting up so
early not so bad come home early in the
evening and say today I really
accomplished something I know I've got
time off that's great
it's like Fallon for sure